question two a one and a half million
dollars question to be five hundred
thousand dollars one of america's most
notorious propagators of conspiracy
theories will now have to pay up and pay
up big for his lies
a jury in texas ordered alex jones to
pay four million dollars in compensary
damages for spreading the lie that the
2012 sandy hook school massacre was a
hoax
the sum of the money in damages is
significant but far below the 150
million families of one of the victims
was asking for
on friday the jury will consider
punitive damages
jones claim was that the mass shooting
in connecticut which killed 20
elementary school children was staged by
actors to bring about stricter u.s gun
control laws
it was lapped up by his millions of
followers some of whom went on to harass
and even issue death threats to the dead
children's parents
jones lawyers argued his statements were
protected by free speech but the parents
of six-year-old jesse lewis one of the
children killed argued the lies were so
malicious and painful they fell outside
the bounds of free speech
it's been a long journey
and it's really really nice to be able
to turn and look at my clients and say
he can't get off scot-free for this he
can't under cross-examination during the
seven-day trial jones admitted the
shooting was quote 100 percent real the
verdict will almost certainly be the
final blow that forces him to close what
remains of his infowars media network
which at its peak was a hugely popular
youtube show and even controversially
had former president donald trump as a
fan
i will not let you down you will be very
very
impressed i hope you know perjury
at one moment during the trial lawyers
for the victims family confronted jones
with two years worth of phone records
and emails
some showing guilt jones own lawyers in
an apparent mishap mistakingly sent them
to the opposing lawyers
it's unknown if jones will face any sort
of criminal charges moving forward but
what is very certain is that his
financial ruin is now all but certain
gabriel lozando al jazeera new york